our major cities did not get the merry
Christmas citizens wanted this year for
some it was a downright scary Christmas
there were many cities where Santa
stayed in the air he was afraid of
getting Sledge act I think we report
isolated crime events throughout the
year particularly in LA and New York but
the National Crime picture often gets
ignored and when you look at the year
that was it takes your breath away or at
least it should this is video of Linda
Fricke a 73 year old grandmother from
New Orleans who was in her car when four
teens rushed it pushing her out freaky
got caught in a safety belt and they
dragged her for about a block severing
her arm from her body she bled to death
in the street
at least they captured her four
attackers but so many times these cases
go unsolved this is just one of the more
than
260 homicides in New Orleans since the
start of the year my hometown of New
Orleans is set to become the murder
capital of the country this week with a
52 percent increase in homicides since
2019. today another man was shot in the
French Quarter and just two days before
Christmas
comedian Brandon Boogie B Montrell was
visiting his family for the holidays he
went to the grocery and was shot to
death possibly by a stray bullet
involving a shootout between others
his mother Sherilyn price explained her
son's death This Way
it's the erosion of the community and
the care for the community
and and and and and and the neglect not
of the city and not of the tourists the
city has neglected its children
boy Miss price is so right the community
and those vowed to protect it have
little regard for human life even young
ones what is driving this pattern of
criminality among our young people and
it's not just New Orleans nationally
homicides and theft have skyrocketed
across the country shooting deaths in
Chicago have become so routine they
barely get mentioned nationally little
children are shot pedestrians and
innocent citizens are caught up in this
Maelstrom of Lawless violence Chicago
will likely end 2022 with 700 murders
just imagine the families missing
relatives this Christmas neighborhoods
without children yet mayor Lori
Lightfoot says things are going just
great look at the improvements and the
murder spree extends to places like
Milwaukee which will end the Year by
breaking its homicide record for the
third year in a row or Kansas City which
will have its second bloodiest year on
record and over at the Mall of America
in Minneapolis inside the Nordstroms the
day before Christmas Eve this happened
oh my God oh my God I think something
just fell I hope something just said
yesterday was the first
Firearms related homicide in the history
of the Mall of America
five people were arrested three juvenile
males who are 17 years old and two adult
males who are 18 years old
19 year old jonte Hudson died in the
store shot authorities got a second
charging extension for the five suspects
today if they don't charge them by noon
tomorrow they'll be released I mean this
is just outrageous we're neglecting our
children by not enforcing the law and by
not making them subject to hard
consequences for deadly actions it's not
Justice to allow kids to kill or steal
without consequences it's gotten to the
point where I know people who actually
hire security to accompany them to the
gas station for a refill if you live in
a place like Philadelphia you can't
blame them the City of Brotherly Love
just broke an all-time record for
carjackings this year they had over a
thousand criminals just pull up to a gas
station with guns and take whatever
vehicle they like it's sort of a thug
car dealership this is now a full-scale
epidemic across the country and in
Chicago there were 19
784 car thefts in the city so far this
year a 99 increase haven't they heard of
uber you can't rent a ride guys you
don't have to boost it this dizzying
cycle of criminality all across America
it should startle and enrage us to
action too often we dismiss the local
headlines and we forget the lives
altered meanwhile our Public Safety and
our children continue to suffer let's
have a true New Year in 2023 and not one
that continues the bloody track record
of the year dying this week hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else